I find that one of the more polarizing
topics in all of medicine and public
health practice is the choice between
environmental determinism at wondon of
the spectrum and personal responsibility
the other so we've got the environmental
determinists and at the extreme I find
that view to be something of an oh woe
is me attitude you know until the world
improves enough around me there's
nothing I can do to help myself and then
there are the personal responsible is to
feel that everybody should pick
themselves up by their bootstraps
regardless of whether or not they've got
boots my view is in between
environmental determinism and personal
responsibility we say where there's a
will there's a way it's not true you
really need both and they're somewhat
independent we must both cultivate will
and pave the way if you inspire an
impassioned people so that they have the
will but there's no way all around them
or walls with no doors or windows it's
terribly frustrating on the other hand
if you put a very nice way at their feet
and they have no will to follow it that
doesn't produce anything very good
either will is not way you need both
knowledge is not power we be we need
both knowledge and the tools the
resources the policies and the programs
to empower people to use what we know in
fact i'm inclined to quote the spiderman
movies now i imagine everybody viewing
this is highly cultured has seen the
spider-man movies one was quite good too
as excellent 3 was a little too
complicated but in any event in the
spider-man movies Peter Parker's uncle
ben says Peter with great power comes
great responsibility I think Public
Health requires a corollary to that
before we ask people to take
responsibility and ultimately we must
people have to own their own health they
must take responsibility but before we
ask them to we must make sure they are
empowered so my view of chronic disease
prevention of fighting epidemic obesity
and diabetes of turning the tide is that
it is the job of professionals to pave
the way and to cultivate the will to
stir people up so that they understand
the stakes so that they recognize that
adult onset diabetes stalking children
is a clear and armed
in danger the wolves are at the door you
must defend hearth and home and here are
the means to do it we must provide
programs policies tools and resources so
that everybody can't do the job